flags are a powerful symbol of identity
but so are crimes that are committed in
the name of hatin in the name of racism
how did a picture of the alleged shooter
Dylan rough how did that on the one hand
spur a narrative change in the
Confederate flag and another a call for
retailers to action two reasons one the
connection of what happened and the
symbol I was it was something that was
waiting to happen and timing made it
happen and for retailers consumers as
you know vote with their wallet it's not
only about the product younger consumers
want to say I like this company i'm
going to support and buy from it and if
they're not doing the right thing
they'll be hung up on the bottom line so
this is one of those things where we see
a tragedy a horrible massacre affect the
social consciousness yeah it the two
issues were out there and they just got
unfortunately connected to this tragedy
the Dwayne this is a debate that
preceded last week's shootings in
Charleston how vocal was that
conversation yeah I mean in a lot of
ways it's like deja vu for people here
in Georgia we went through a
considerable knock-down drag-out over
the Confederate battle emblem here more
than a decade ago it used to be part of
our state's flag we had a governor who
should have been reelected by a
landslide by all experts who lost in
part because he cut a deal with the
legislature to get rid of the
Confederate battle emblem or to reduce
it to a small box on the flag his the
winner of that election came back had
promised a referendum pushed for
potentially the Confederate battle
emblem to return the business community
who had fought it before rose up again
and said it would be bad for economic
development they eventually ended up
with the flag we have now which actually
is still the stars and bars which were
part of the first national flag of the
Confederate States but people largely
here believe the debate is in the past
in Georgia mr. Adamson how do you
explain the fact that national retailers
are pulling the Confederate flag and
similar merchandise from their websites
and from their store shelves
but manufacturers their sales of the
flag or surging it's going to take time
for the two to catch up the retailers
and the brands need to do the right
thing they need to follow what's going
on and follow their conscious and be
good corporate citizens the
manufacturers when they're not being
sold anymore through retail will soon
find out that the market is going to
vaporize is this one of those things sir
where you see people doing stuff not
because it's the right thing to do not
because they have some sense of moral
outrage but is it business expediency I
think they're doing it for both reasons
I think retailers Nate now and brands
today need to bend over backwards to do
the right thing because consumers as i
said earlier vote with their wallet and
if they don't like the behavior of a
company a brand or an organization they
will let them know very quickly and
social media empowers that a duane as
you mentioned in georgia big fight over
the Confederate flag more than a decade
ago at that time the business community
wanted the flag to stay what's the
community the business community saying
now yeah I mean they would absolutely
still agree with that they want no part
of that battle emblem in the state they
feel like it makes a southern state look
backwards in it and it feels like if
companies carmakers for instance are
looking at a couple of states they may
shy away from a state that in essence
with a symbol tells part of its
population that maybe they're worth less
than another part of the population so
you're not going to see any big fight
some of that now but the people there
are people who still believe that flag
represents there's the south it
represents the pride of the south I
think that's becoming more and more
clear that that's a difficult argument
to make in the least it's an argument
that in essence shows a lack of empathy
for another part of the population and
especially given what that flag
represents in the past mr adamson you
spoke a moment ago about the internet
our colleagues and bloomberg editorial
they wrote the following today and i
quote while governments may take 150
years to act ecommerce can move in a
flash has the internet helped to change
the heritage versus racism debate in the
southern US
I think it's the more knowledge and more
information sharing that happens the
faster policies have to change the
fasters brands have to react the fastest
markers have correct so I think it has
put a magnifying glass on what was
always true and turned up the volume and
moved to action fast and sir some of
these retailers who decided they weren't
going to sell a flag or pull some of
that merchandise is there a risk for
them doing so no the risk would be to
continue to sell the merchandise they
are doing the prudent thing for their
brand and for their business which is
following what's happening on social
media following how people feel about
them and following a good corporate
citizenship I'll